انا اقدر
اخذ جوال وافتح اي شيء اقدر ادفعه شوي
اقدر ادخل اي حساب عنده اشترك في اي شيء
بيه اسوي اي شيء
تستاهل
عبد الله جنيه
العمر 25 حاليا انا اشتغل
في القطاع البنك
في احدى قطعه
بصراحه
رهيب يعني مميز صراحه يعطيك ميزه ونتقابل
اي واحد يعني ترى الناس توائم قليل
يعتبرون فان واحد يشوفك تمام فشيء صراحه
مميز انت تشوفها بطريقه مختلفه ان هذا زيك
بس ترى اخوك يعني انت عندك
شعور انه هذا اخوك اللهم الفرق الوحيد
بيني وبين اي اخو ثاني هو هو العمر وانكم
[موسيقى]
ترى الناس ممكن يعني يحسن موضوع هذا يعني
شيء مر خطير بس انه انك انت مجرد انك انت
عندك توام الخصيه اللي بينكم تقل بشكل
طبيعي فعشان كذا ما في مشكله والله ما في
خصيه اغلب الاشياء لن اعرفها
هذا الشيء يعني ما يخلي خصوصيا مره مشكله
كبيره بس انه عنده قدم يشوف اي شيء في
يعني قوانين غير مكتوبه
خلاص يعني في اشياء
فانت ما تدخل فيها مع ان عندك المقدمه
بسهوله جدا يكفي انك تفتح جوالك بوجهك
فيعني انت عندك يعني جميع
تنظر لها منظور ثاني ان التوام ترى فعليا
كانك كانك متزوج انت واحد معك 24 ساعه
تقول والله اليوم انسبوع المرح قاعد
اخوك دايما
في ميزه حلوه يعني فكره انه عندك توام نفس
جميع يعني اهتماماتك ونفس ذوقك ونفس كل
شيء هذا يريحك مره بالاكل تخليه يذوق واذا
عجبها انت تاكل تختصر لك يعني في المتابعه
تابع فيلم بالله اذا خلصتها
واهم شيء الصراحه بالنسبه لي يمكن يعني
حاليا قاعد تصير يعني كل واحد يمشي في في
علاقاته وفي الاخير يعني العلاقات تتجمع
بالاخير يعني كل واحد انا عارفه انه هو
اخوي نفس الشكل اللي اعرفه هو بيعرفهم
واللي هو يعرفهم ما نعرفهم بس الاهتمام
للشخص مثلا انت تعرف شخص معين شافك شخص
وعرفك زين فما شاف واحد زيك نسخه منك هذا
الشيء على طول بيكسر حواجز كثيره عاطل
بيدخل منطقه اللي اوكي انا عارفك صراحه
يعني مره كبيره وتصير دائما ترى حنا مسوين
نظام كامل جميع اشياء حياتيه بمعنى ان
حاطين نظام اندور وانا دور اشياء معينه
وانا اسوي اشياء معينه وتنقسم مثلا ليل
نهار وتغير مع الوقت فانتم كانكم شخص واحد
مشاويركم تنقسم بينكم مرات مثلا في
الطلعات عند عندكم مثلا اكثر من جروب جروب
بيطلع وانت مالك خلق تطلعون سوا خلاص تطلع
اضغط عني نفسي مع العزايم خلاص ترى في حال
واحد جاء يغطي عنه
[موسيقى]
تخيل مثلا شخص معين جاب درجه معينه هذه هو
اللي فيها مثلا ليش هو اعلى منك
تكون التبرير يعني ما
يعني
لكن طرف الاخر
خفت درجه اقل زعلت مره فقلت ليش مره الحمد
لله يعني
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
فكره انه
يختبر انا واثق نفسي اكثر من وانا واثق
نفسي اكثر اني اخش فكل واحد يقول والله
انا بذاكر زين انا بخش وبجيب ان شاء الله
غلطت انا غلطان يعني
[موسيقى]
فبعد تقريبا تقريبا سنه ما شفته
عبد الرحمن قلت له انت تطلع معاه فطلع
معاه سولف معه قاعد بقابلهم
[موسيقى]
يعني
افضل اريح كل مواضيع يعني بيصير يعني مثلا
اغراضي
[موسيقى]
الموضوع يعني ترى
صغير
مقارنات تدبل ميه مره عندي مشكله
اخوك سوى كذا ليش ما تسوي كذا والعكس صحيح
طبعا أنتَ وليش كذا
سوا فهم اكيد بيتناقشون اكيد اكيد
مستحيل يكون يعني اي
يعني اي خصوصيه
[موسيقى]
انا اهدا منك
هو مزعج ولا لا
شيء ثاني ممكن اول ما اتعرف على شخص جديد
عبدالله يكون منفتح اكثر
انا اكون اكثر من يعني ممكن
استغل فرص اكثر يعني انفتاح الاستغلال
فرصه اكثر يعني يكفي اصلا هذه المقابله
يعني انا كنت شويه يعني ضدها نوعا ما بس
نجرب
سبحان الله
توقعتك تخوني والله
[موسيقى]